c'est la fin d'un calvaire pour ces
civils qui escaladent les ruines de la
série age of talent filmé ici par les
hommes du bataillon azoff des bus
affrété par les nations unies les dépose
dans la ville de bézy mène à 30 km à
l'est de marioupol sous contrôle russe
natalia était employé chez asos talent
pendant deux mois elle est restée
réfugier dans les sous sols de lusine
les bombardements étaient si forts
qu'ils résonnait juste au dessus d'une à
la sortie de l'abri anti bombes ou de
quelques marches on a enfants commencent
à respirer car il n'y avait pas assez
d'oxygène sous terre j'aurais pu sortir
respirer de l'air frais mais je ne les
jamais fait j'avais trop peur les russes
affirment que les évacués de marioupol
qui le souhaitent peuvent se rendre dans
des territoires contrôlés par kiev un
premier groupe de civils est attendu à
zaporijia
surpêche aujourd'hui pour la première
fois depuis le début de la guerre ce
couloir humanitaire vitale a commencé à
fonctionner pour la première fois il est
le deux jours de cessez-le-feu dans
cette zone l'usinage ostal derniers
bastions de la résistance ukrainienne à
marioupol est un enjeu stratégique
sur ces images fournies par l'entreprise
américaine maksar le complexe
sidérurgique apparaît totalement détruit
par les bombardements
ce vendredi les fusilliers marins
ukrainiens ont déclaré que 600 soldats
blessés et des centaines de civils
restait retranché dans les sous sols du
site le régiment azoff un bataillon de
résistants fondé par des membres de
l'extrême droite ukrainienne a publié
cette vidéo
nous sommes coincés ici depuis trop
longtemps isolé encerclé donc ce plus
approvisionné et nos vivres s'épuisent
selon un officier ukrainien lui aussi
présent à azov stahl les bombardements
sur la syrie aurait repris dès la fin
des évacuations